la parole est à monsieur marc le fur
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à vous monsieur le ministre
des finances elle porte sur le
prélèvement à la source
vous nous présenter cette réforme comme
une réforme technique dont l'objectif
est la simplification
pas du tout vous allez compliquer la vie
de nos entreprises et en particulier la
vie nos petites entreprises dont parlait
très justement monsieur touré vous allez
transformer ces entreprises en
collecteurs d'impôts elles devront
demain verser au fisc l'impôt dû par
leurs propres salariés
mettez vous à la place d'un boulanger
d'un d'artisans pour ce look pour celui
ci cela représentera une charge de
travail disproportionné qui risquent
demain de le dissuader encore un peu
plus d'embauché d'autre part les
salariés seront victimes de cette
réforme il perdons un élément halak et
auquel tient tiennent la confidentialité
de l'impôt de salariés qui gagnent
aujourd'hui la même chose parce qu'ils
n'auront pas le même prélèvement à la
source en raison des revenus de la
famille et bien cela ce sera autant
d'informations dont disposeront les
chefs d'entreprise moi je croise des
salariés qui me disent moi j'aime bien
mon patron mais j'ai pas envie qu'ils
sachent ce que gagne mon conjoint
moi j'aime bien mon patron mais j'ai pas
envie qu'ils sachent s'ils bénéficient
d'une pension alimentaire ou si je verse
une pension alimentaire
autant de choses qui relèvent du cercle
familial
or l'entreprise demain aura connaissance
ne serait ce monsieur le ministre que
parce que le tout par le taux de l'impôt
de l'existence d'autres revenus
d'autre part ce genre d'information dont
disposerait demain une direction des
personnels va polluer considérablement
la négociation salariale à salé en
s'alliant salariés méritants pourrait se
voir refuser une augmentation au vu des
revenus familiaux qui sont suffisamment
confortable autant d'éléments dont
l'entreprise n'a pas à connaître
monsieur le ministre vous avancer masqué
dans cette réforme
ce que vous voulez faire opérer c'est
revenir à la fusion de la csg et l'impôt
sur revenu
merci monsieur le jeu en a pas on est à
monsieur christian eckert
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
marc le fur
les principes de la retenue à la source
sont très simples premièrement c'est la
direction générale des finances
publiques qui restera le seul
interlocuteur du contribuable est le
seul renseignement qui sera transmis à
l'employeur c'est le taux d'imposition
deuxièmement le taux d'imposition d'un
foyer fiscal ou sur le député dans 90%
des cas il est compris entre 0 et 10 %
et la connaissance d'un taux monsieur le
député même pour des spécialistes
fiscaux comme vous ne donne aucun
renseignement le même taux peut
correspondre à des situations familiales
extrêmement différente et l'employeur
n'aura pas connaissance ensuite monsieur
le député
quelle est la finalité de cette réforme
la france pourrait-elle être le dernier
où quasiment pays au monde à ne pas
mettre en place le vote nul assez vous
plaît la finalité c'est de pouvoir
adapter le montant de l'impôt payé au
moment où l'on perçoit le revenu pour un
salarié qui part en retraite
pour un salarié qui verrait ses revenus
diminuer
n'est-il pas logique de pouvoir voir son
impôt immédiatement s'adapter à sa
nouvelle situation pour un couple qui
change de situation familiale qui
accueille un enfant
n'est-il pas normal qu'ils puissent
immédiatement bénéficié de la demi part
fiscale supplémentaire alors vous nous
dites c'est une charge considérable pour
les employeurs
monsieur le député un certain nombre
d'organisations passent leur temps à
nous dire que nous serions trop lent à
faire des réformes
eh bien les mêmes nous disent
aujourd'hui que cette réforme qui est un
progrès pour les couples pour les
familles et beaucoup trop rapide le
parlement demain le travail commence en
commission des finances saura se montrer
à la hauteur
merci monsieur mini cela par l'état
monsieur